>> YOU DO KNOW LITTLE GIRLS CAN
GO AS FAR AS THEIR IMAGINATIONS
WILL TAKE THEM.
LIKE OUTER SPACE.
>> LIFTOFF!
>> THE STREETS OF PARIS?
BONJOUR.
OR A MAGICAL WORLD THEY CREATED
ALL ON THEIR OWN?
>> THIS IS HOW YOU GET TO THE
CASTLE.
>> AND TO SHOW JUST HOW FAR WE
MATTEL IS PROUD TO
INTRODUCE PRESIDENT'S BARBIE,
THE FIRST BARBIE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
>> OH, NEAT.
>> OH, DON'T YOU WANT TO PLAY
WITH HER.
SHE'S A GIRL.
JUST LIKE YOU.
>> YEAH, BUT GIRLS DON'T HAVE TO
PLAY WITH DOLLS.
WE CAN PLAY WITH WHATEVER WE
WANT.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO PLAY WITH
DOLLS.
BUT IT WOULD BE GREAT IF YOU
PLAYED WITH THIS DOLL RIGHT NOW.
>> I LIKE LEGOS.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU SOUND LIKE.
>> LOOK --
>> PRESIDENT BARBIE COMES WITH
ACCESSORIES LIKE SUNGLASSES AND
SMART PHONE WITH SNAPCHAT.
DO YOU LIKE HER NOW?
HUH?
DO YOU?
>> LOOKS LIKE SHE IS TRYING TOO
HARD.
>> SHE IS TRYING HARD.
BECAUSE
THERE USED TO BE A TIME WHEN
BARBIE COULDN'T EVEN BE
PRESIDENT.
>> I WASN'T ALIVE THEN.
>> GOOD FOR YOU.
>> I JUST DON'T LIKE HER.
SHE IS TOO STIFF.
>> I BET YOU WOULD LIKE
PRESIDENT BARBIE IF SHE SMILED
MORE TOO?
>> YEAH.
>> WOW, YOU REALLY DON'T GET IT,
DO YOU?
>> HEY, DO YOU KNOW WHAT WILL BE
FUN?
IF WE
PLAYED WITH THAT OLD BROOM OVER
THERE.
>> YEAH!
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY GO WITH.
UH --
WE NEED TO RETHINK THIS WHOLE
THING.
>> HEY, GIRLS, WHY DON'T YOU
PLAY WITH PRESIDENT BARBIE?
>> BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TO!
>> OH.
>> PRESIDENT BARBIE, NO FUN,
DEFINITELY A PRESIDENT.
[ APPLAUSE ]